[Musique]
nous appelons les américains à faire
un vote moral dans un vote
euh priant et prophétique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je veux dire si je m'endors avant,
je vérifierai juste le matin certains
endroits disent  que biden est en tête,
certains endroits disent que l'atout est
en tête et je ne sais pas à qui faire confiance
à ce stade,
c'est comme des couches d'anxiété, je suis
anxieux depuis quatre ans ou plus
au lieu de rester à la maison en ne regardant
que les nouvelles que nous avons pensé  que nous passerions du
temps avec les gens que nous aimons
attendre les résultats des élections
et profiter de la compagnie de chacun
à propos des résultats que nous
attendons toujours sur l'arizona, le michigan et quelques
autres états,
donc je vérifie mon téléphone toutes les cinq
minutes, j'ai hâte que ce soit fini
pour être honnête
[Musique]
je ne suis pas anxieux je pense que l'amérique
va de l'avant
et notre génération et les gens sont
plus conscients et voient plus de vérité
qui se passe
c'est incroyable
[Applaudissements]
je suis heureux de l'
élection de Joe Biden
comment vous vous sentez qui est votre nouveau président
ça fait quatre ans d'enfer quatre ans
à
se sentir comme si nous n'avions pas d'importance et maintenant nous
savons que les gens savent que nous comptons
toi